aujourd'hui nous sommes à le port marly
au cri aux folles on va tester la
cryothérapie corps entier alors elle
aurait de nombreux bienfaits limiterait
le stress agirait sur des rhumatismes
améliorerait le sommeil et tonifier la
peau elle est plus souvent connu pour
les sportifs mais elle devient grand
plus vite à aujourd'hui on va tester
avant de passer dans la cabine un
entretien de 15 minutes doit être
effectuée avec une infirmière pour un
bilan de santé
alors je vous donne le bilan à remplir
on accorde donc si les pathologies voilà
l'évaluation de la douleur de 0 à 10
et puis on va prendre la tension juste
avant de passer dans la machine faisait
le bras détendez vous respirez bien un
truc qui le mot alors une fois le
questionnaire rempli on va se changer il
faut un bonnet un masque des gants et
des grosses chaussettes
alors voilà après avoir passé
l'entretien après m'être changé je vais
rentrer dans la cabine à -85 degrés
pendant trois minutes
la première minute est plutôt agréable
ensuite le froid devient de plus en plus
présent tout en restant supportable on
voit des cristaux de glace se former sur
la peau
[Musique]
vient de sortir il faisait très très
froid
c'était très long trois minutes mais
finalement ça va on a besoin que la peau
qu'on gèle mais en sortant c'est le
soulagement
[Musique]
alors vous êtes yana louis le directeur
du centre
une séance de cryothérapie c'est à dire
combien de temps trois minutes en tant
que tel la première séance a duré à peu
près le tout quarante minutes puisque on
va faire un bilan et donc ce centre il
n'est pas réservé uniquement aux
sportifs non non il est réel il est
réservé à personne il est pour tous les
publics
nous faisons un accroc thérapie corps
entier qui est très connu pour la
récupération sportive mais également qui
est très bon pour toutes les pathologies
en flammes à 3 donc tous les gens qui
ont des douleurs des inflammations des
maladies chroniques inflammatoires
spondylarthrite arthrite arthrose
peuvent faire de la clôture
la séance finie alors ici faut compter
29 euros pour une séance découverte et
on peut y acculer à partir de saison
avec une autorisation parentale